who practiced how to pronounce the team
that Rick Pitino's coaching Pauly Natha
for not the Negros but not the nakos yes
is that it yeah I believe that's good
Reis
yeah he's gone to Greece Panathinaikos
there it's a legendary team in Greece
where Rick Pitino is going and coach
joins us now it took us I don't know 10
minutes to be able to come up with how
to pronounce that name how long did it
take you well about as long as some of
the people who called me on the phone to
speak to me about the job so it's a I
think I'm gonna call everybody by that
first name Juna do you know the roster I
do I've been watching film you know I
haven't 100% taking the job
my family's all flying in for the
holidays and I owe it to them to discuss
with them but I have studied the film
they're obviously losing that's why they
fired the coach you know it's basketball
over there is quite different I coached
the Puerto Rican national team it's it's
like the old NBA in terms of physicality
the days of when I coached Oakley and
Ewing extremely physical it's not like
the NBA today the offense of passing and
spacing is great but it's very physical
basketball all right your family's
coming in for the holidays what if your
family says you know what we don't want
you to go to Greece then pretty much you
know they have sacrificed for me all my
life they have picked up and traveled at
moment's notice and they're the most
important thing in any family's life as
your children and your wife and
certainly they know how much I love
teaching a game they know how much I
miss it that being said if they're
against it I'm I'm gonna go by their
wishes but you said it's not official
yet what are you waiting on just them
I think the contracts will set there I
haven't seen it yet but I think it's all
said just want their approval that's
really really important to me and then
I'll just take off for six months and
the one thing I don't want to do is stop
learning you know even at 66 when you I
can watch 100 games a week and it's not
like being on the sidelines
I don't want to stop learning once a
teacher always a teacher and I'm excited
to get back on the sidelines but it was
a couple months ago back in September
when you said you were done when you
were on the show what changed well I was
really really down in the dumps at
Louisville for not even waiting to see
the verdict of my innocence and then I
was even more upset at the Southern
District of New York and and even more
so today when they came out in the trial
and exonerated me
they used people to show my innocence
basically no that wasn't their intention
but got people up understand and said no
we kept it from Rick Pitino he was not
to know the dad said that the guy guess
and always said that and but they had
all that information when this all
started and instead of saying Rick
Pitino was innocent at that time they
used me for publicity for the this
so-called scandal I don't know how much
scandal that actually is and but they
had all that information on tape that I
did not know anything and they put my
name alone with Jim Larranaga in a
complaint and all it did was put my name
on the front page of newspapers and make
me look like I did know something and it
hurt but that being said it's time to
let go to bitterness it's time to get
back on the sidelines and start teaching
again but do you feel like the FBI made
you the face of this investigation the
poster boy they did but I don't know if
it's the FBI as much as the prosecutors
the prosecutors the FBI gathers the
information are they they had the Y
attempts of all these people saying we
got to keep it from Rick Pitino he
doesn't know about it
so they had that information but they
still put my name in a complaint based
on this car not as saying oh we'll call
Rick Pitino and he's tight with adidas
he's the Big Shot at adidas he'll get us
more money and that was a total con job
the guy obviously not knowing he was
speaking to the FBI so I don't know if
it was the FBI they just gather I think
the FBI just gathers information gathers
the evidence and then the prosecutors
decide what to do with it I was Wonder
when I saw the news that you were gonna
take this job or at least contemplating
it it's that desire to have a positive
at the end of your resume if this is
your last job you know it was gonna be
Louisville and this is what was gonna be
on your basketball tombstone and I
wondered how you can sort of rewrite
your coaching legacy or at least the
ending of it how important is that to
you it's important and even though you
know so many people call me to
congratulate me on the trial and say
you're in I said yeah I said where did
did you read it on what page did you
read it on page 35 instead of being on
the front page it brought to mind a
Tommy Lasorda quote he said when you
know you think you have your troubles
and you realize 80% of the people really
don't care and then the other 20% really
enjoy that you have them and I always
laughed at that quote it's really true
80% of people really don't care that you
you may be innocent and the other 20% of
glad you went through that pain so it's
it's something I don't I didn't want to
leave the game like that I knew from day
one I would not tolerate anything that
went on that dormitory I knew it would
not tolerate anything that would hurt
the university or hurt more important
hurt the players so I didn't want to
leave on that note and I'm hoping that
Greece is not my last step maybe I'll
love it and want to stay over there or
stay in the Euroleague or try the NBA or
go back to college whatever opportunity
may be out there for me but I didn't
want to leave on that note talking to
Rick Pitino Continental Tire Coaches
Corner and at 66 I don't know how long
you want to continue to coach but you
strike me as almost Joe Paterno like
Brent Musburger said there are certain
people who have a job as a coach and
then there are there are coaches and you
kind of fall into that category like
Paterno Brent said when Paterno stops
coaching he'll die and that's what
happened well you know it's funny that
you say that because even though I was
in Miami and even though I was doing
things I've never done before and in
somewhat enjoying life there wouldn't be
a moment that would go by at the end of
the night
I'd have a difficult time shutting my
eyes with realizing how much I missed it
it's it's in your blood it's an
addiction coaching is an addiction it's
like anything else you've missed a
camaraderie with the players you missed
the development with the players you
missed the intensity on the sidelines
you missed a competitive nature of the
game itself and you just can't live
without it you really can I know I can't
some people can like al McGuire Dave
Gavitt they did a great job with a
retired John Wooden they were fabulous
said stepping away from the game I just
have a very difficult time putting my
ice to bed at night thinking I'm not
going to coach the next day I was
telling my guys this morning about what
you were talking about the physicality
of coaching there I did your predecessor
get fired for threatening a referee at
the end of a game that he won that was
the owner I'll be I'll be offered and I
think it was a both referees that got me
a little nervous when I read that but I
have spoken with the owner he's a very
passionate man who wants to win and but
he's he loves this team and as great he
doesn't get involved with the actual
coaching part so that's good
well you he doesn't care for referees
you took your team's over there didn't
you and yes I played like my Kentucky
teams went over there and played their
back in a day obviously I coached the
Puerto Rican national team and that's
the same favor basketball is the same
physical type basketball and you know
I'm quite knowledgeable about it but
let's face it look I'm sure the coach
that was with go has a great experience
I'm sure he's an outstanding basketball
coach so it it comes to mind it do you
have the players to win can you maybe
add roster and improve the players I
think that's something that their
ownership is looking at and can you
motivate the players to play better at
the defensive end offensively you're not
going to change a whole lot when you
first get when you come in the middle of
the season you make subtle changes but
at the defensive end you've got to make
a lot of serious changes because that's
generally why you're losing you got
white and
as the colors over there I think the
first game white suit blue tie nice
little statement there coach we're
playing ma Scouts and it's the league is
quite interesting because you go to
Spain Italy and Moscow you go to Tel
Aviv and Lithuania and Germany and it's
really exciting as far as that's
concerned to see all these different
countries and an experience that it's
something I've not done and looking
forward to it you got an invitation from
Coach Cal to go back to Kentucky are you
gonna take him up on that offer to get
an ovation you know what to tell you the
truth I when I wrote that book I called
it Camelot I spent seven years at
Kentucky and didn't have a bad day it
was the opposite of the last few years
at Louisville never had a bad day took
over a scandal-ridden program and turned
it around where we went to three Final
Fours and actually with my assistant we
had three championship games in a row
which is unheard of but the student body
at Kentucky look at me as a Louisville
coach and they were not born when I was
the Kentucky coach they probably have
very little knowledge except from their
parents what I did at Kentucky so I
relied told John I really appreciated
the invite it was so nice of him to
think of me but I'm gonna let him do his
thing and I don't need to cry anymore
cry if they gave me a great ovation cry
if they booed me up cried enough in my
life you know what just bring Laettner
with you and then you know that they're
gonna hang somebody more than you coach
that's exactly true hey congrats safe
travels Happy Holidays to you and good
luck dad thank you so much happy
Holidays to you that's Rick Pitino
headed to Greece it looks like not
officially official but looks like he'll
be coaching again and I think wanting
the opportunity to coach in the NBA
again or college basketball again so
maybe you do a pit-stop over there for a
year or season then you come back for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel two three
9:00 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]